[Music]
if you have a fascination with cartoons
you're going to love this video we've
gathered up some photos of a few of the
most popular and lovable cartoon animals
and their real-life twins you'll
definitely have to do a double-take when
you see these pictures just wait until
we show you the photo of the real-life
cast of 101 Dalmatians it's absolutely
epic if you're new to our channel click
the red subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up today we're
showing you 10 amazing photos of cartoon
animals in their real-life version Simba
as one of the top grossing Disney films
The Lion King has made over 300 billion
dollars at the box office there's a
reason why this film is popular and it
all has to do with its relatable
characters and it's heartwarming
storylines everyone immediately fell in
love with Mufasa the strong playful and
kind-hearted father to Simba when Simba
was first born the baby cub had golden
brown hair and big black eyes
he was absolutely adorable don't you
think what would you think if we told
you there was a real-life version of
baby Simba well guess what we found this
picture of a baby cub that looks a lot
like the Disney character this little
lion not only looks like Simba but we'd
bet he's strong-willed energetic and
curious too the only thing missing is
the real-life version of Mufasa scar and
Nala wouldn't it be amazing to see The
Lion King recreated using real animals
we know it would probably never happen
since animals of the wild deserve to be
left and bothered in their natural
habitats but it's still fun to think of
what a real version of The Lion King
would be like don't you think scooby-doo
the first episode of scooby-doo
premiered all the way back in 1969 even
though it has been decades since the
show was released the main character is
still as popular now as he was back then
the animated series has had several
spin-off shows made-for-tv movies and
feature films
what makes Scooby our favorite old buddy
is his adorable voice his loyalty and
how protective he is of his nephew
scrappy-doo
skooby is the type of dog we all wish we
could have in real life we're a little
disappointed that he's only a cartoon
character how about you well not so fast
check out this photo of a great day and
that looks a lot like scooby he even has
the distinctive black spots on his fur
and a similar body shape just like the
animated character Great Danes are huge
dogs just like Scooby but they differ in
one major way scooby sometimes gets
scared really easily especially when
there's a ghost or a monster lurking
around and Great Danes tend to be
courageous and they're never timid in
the face of danger but aside from those
differences these two are definitely
twinning Dory and Marlin
the world didn't realize how much it was
absolutely in love with fish until the
2003 release of Finding Nemo in the
movie the fish story helps Marlin on a
vast search through the ocean to find
his son Nemo Dory proved to be a good
companion on the journey although her
short-term memory loss stood in the way
of her remembering Nemo's name but her
optimism was infectious with her bright
blue color and yellow fins she
definitely stands out on the big screen
Marlin is a bit smaller than Dory but
that doesn't mean he's any less powerful
throughout the film Marlin finds the
strength and wisdom within himself to
search through the ocean and bring his
son back home with so many species of
fish in the world it's no surprise that
we found two that look exactly like Dory
and Marlin are you ready to see them
here they are this is an actual photo of
real fish inside an aquarium the big
blue one looks a lot like Dory and the
smaller one looks exactly like Marlin
Disney needs to hire these two for a
Finding Nemo live-action remake ASAP
Bambi and flower can you believe it was
back in 1942 when the world was first
introduced to Bambi it didn't take long
for generation after generation to fall
head over heels in love with the main
character in the film Bambi is in a bed
of colorful flowers he stumbles upon a
skunk and he mistakes him for a pretty
flower he then gives the skunk the name
flower and a
with thumper the three animals become
instant friends when flower Falls hard
for a female skunk named Miss skunk the
to become an item and have a child
together they decide to name their baby
Bambi in honor of the main character to
name his child after the deer is proof
that these two are truly BFF this photo
from the film shows the moment when
Bambi and flower first made contact with
each other aren't they adorable now are
you ready to see the real-life twins in
action
voila this is a photo of an actual deer
getting up close and personal with a
skunk the deer looks so much like the
animated character from its wide eyes
and its coat of brown fur with white
spots what are your thoughts on the
real-life Bambi and flower Gus
most people are afraid of mice unless
the mouse is Gus from the movie
Cinderella of course aside from Mickey
Mouse Gus is definitely one of the most
favorite mice in the history of cartoons
he's a bit tiny in size but that doesn't
mean he's lacking courage and
determination when Cinderella is
threatened by anyone guess who always
comes to her rescue its Gus who never
hesitates to throw up his fists to fight
for the Disney Princesses honor
we just love this photo of the animated
character he's doing what he does best
devouring some cheese and how could you
not love his to buckteeth they're
perfect for knowing on his favorite
snack if you thought there could never
be a real-life Mouse that looked exactly
like Gus well think again we're about to
show you a picture that will make your
jaw drop are you ready
let us introduce you to the real-life
version of Gus he may not be the same
color as the Disney character but check
him out he looks so sweet and innocent
and he's going to town on that piece of
cheese 101 Dalmatians
calling all Disney fans cartoon
enthusiasts and animal lovers 101
Dalmatians contains all of these
elements and it really makes for an
awesome animated movie the Disney film
is all about a litter of puppies
to their parents Pongo and Perdita sadly
they're kidnapped by a villain Cruella
De Vil in the film we get to learn more
about the personalities of each dog
Tredici
exhibits many of the traits that are
found in human cartoon characters she's
classy elegant and very well-spoken
she's definitely what we would call a
warrior and she's willing to do whatever
it takes to fight for her family
Pongo is the complete opposite he's very
playful a little bit goofy and easygoing
but together they make an awesome pair
and they're intense love for their
puppies is undeniable now we're about to
show you a real-life Pongo and Perdita
are you ready
tada here they are these two Dalmatians
look so much like the Disney characters
right down to their collars one is
decked out in blue and the other dog is
wearing a red collar just like the two
animated characters what do you think
are these two dogs the carbon copies of
Pongo and Perdita Dumbo this just might
be one of the most adorable pictures
we've ever seen this is a photo of Dumbo
the high-flying elephant with a
childlike personality the Disney
character is innocent a bit naive and
very playful it's so easy to fall in
love with its character especially when
you see this photo of him as a
teeny-tiny baby does he look so innocent
we just want to pick him up and cuddle
with him forever if you've been to the
zoo or if you've gone on an African
safari you've probably seen a real-life
baby elephant before but we guarantee
you've never seen one just as cute as
Dumbo until now
this little elephant is Dumbo's
long-lost twins don't you think they
have the same big floppy ears and this
real elephant seems to be just as
cheerful joyful and fun-loving as the
animated character the only thing
missing from the real-life Dumbo is his
magic feather to give him the ability to
fly bolt
both stole our hearts when he was first
revealed in his self-titled movie back
in 2008 in case you're not familiar with
his story we'll tell you a little bit
more about his background the Disney
character was adopted by penny when he
was just a little puppy he grew up on a
TV set and he played the role of a
superhero puppy when he escaped from the
film set he soon realized that the
powers he thought he had weren't real
after all when it came to the design of
the character Disney animators may have
received inspiration from a breed of dog
called a polar bear white German
Shepherd bolt has the same white glossy
coat of fur and the same pointy ears
that stand straight up on his head if
you're not convinced that bolt is truly
a German Shepherd just check out this
photo of his real-life animal twin
looking at these two photos side by side
is more than enough proof that the pup
is actually living among us in the real
world even though they look almost
exactly alike who do you think is cuter
bolt or his real-life animal twin Timon
and Pumbaa can you name a more iconic
duo than Timon and Pumbaa yeah
neither can we these characters from The
Lion King made us lol with their
hilarious jokes every time they appeared
on the screen we knew they were going to
say something to make us burst out into
laughter when it comes to their
appearance Timon has the typical
features of a meerkat he has a thin and
lanky body a long tail and various
shades of brown fur on his body
Pumbaa on the other hand is a brownish
red warthog with a huge pink snout and
squinty eyes together this comedic team
of characters is set to appear in the
live-action remake of the Lion King
we're super anxious to see them on the
big screen but this photo of their
real-life twins will hold us over for
now look at how cute this warthog is
even though the meerkat appears to be
having a rough day
she looks pretty adorable too their
real-life Timon and Pumbaa are far from
best friends perhaps they could bond
over the fireflies in the skies just
like the movie characters did
do you like the cartoon characters or
the real-life versions of tea
boomba better react in the comments
section down below we can't wait to see
what you have to say winnie-the-pooh
winnie-the-pooh has a very long history
that dates back to 1926 the world was
introduced to the bear through a story
written by an author named Alan
Alexander Milne many of the characters
in the original story were inspired by
real-life people in the author's life
Christopher Robin
whose BFF was named after the author's
son and while growing up the author's
son had a teddy bear which he named
Winnie the bear was named after a
real-life bear that had been adopted as
a cub by a Canadian soldier during World
War one okay that's enough of this
history lesson let's get into the photo
shall we this picture shows who and all
of his adorable glory he's wearing his
signature red shirt and there's a purple
butterfly just hanging out on his nose
now are you ready to see the real-life
version of Winnie the Pooh check him out
this photo of a brown bear with a
butterfly on his nose looks a lot like
the drawing of Pooh they almost have the
same expression on their faces don't you
think are you a huge Winnie the Pooh fan
which of these photos of the real-life
version of cartoon animals is your
favorite start a conversation in the
comment section below if you enjoyed
this video don't forget to subscribe to
our Channel thanks for watching
[Music]